foreign
[Music]
Jason Momoa trading movie sets for the
friendly Skies well I can't say it okay
maybe not exactly but he did try his
hand at being a flight attendant albeit
briefly yeah the star went from Aquaman
[Applause]
[Music]
to Aquaman on a Hawaiian Airlines flight
over the weekend that's the island
native looking very Dapper behind the
service cart in a gray suit jacket
accessorized with a lay and pink flower
behind his ear walking down the aisle to
pass out water bottles to the passengers
[Music]
foreign
so what called for Jason's surprise
appearance well it turns out it was a
marketing stunt for his company meninu
pure water I feel like it's my
responsibility it's my mission to clean
up the oceans clean up the land for my
kids for yours for the world
's future aluminum for a plastic free
environment we gotta save our oceans we
gotta save our landfills now if the
acting stuff doesn't work out for Jason
and the water company goes away we think
it's safe to say he's got a career in
the sky
thank you
and speaking of flying high there's a
chance Jason's on Cloud9 with his
rekindled flame Aza Gonzalez last week
the two were spotted taking a ride on
his motorcycle following the news of a
breakup in June is and Jason were first
romantically linked in May and they were
friends before that at the time A source
told E.T there was always underlying
chemistry for the pair
I got a lot of
guys going on but things seem fizzled
out the following month but not long
after the spark was re-lit as fans
caught Jason and Aza out together again
just weeks later trying to be a
gentleman The Source recently told E.T
the two are hanging out when it's
convenient quote they're both busy in
their own lives and with work so it's
difficult to have a serious relationship
but they do still enjoy each other's
company and like each other and wherever
this romance takes them EET is along for
the ride which is kind of how his
explained her approach to love back in
2017. I I like to be the ride or die I'm
very I'm very writer die I'm there no
matter what time like I'm that girl I
have not gotten very lucky I'm gonna go
to the same amount but you know what
I'll get my ride or die eventually
[Music]